Overdoses, relapses, and rehab doesn't
sound like a recipe for a successful
comedy - but Chuck Lorre pulled it off for
eight seasons with his smash hit "Mom."
If you've ever dreamed of making it in showbiz and
need a bit of inspiration, check out Chuck Lorre's
story. Lorre, the creator of "Mom," along with a
host of other hit sitcoms, spent many years broke
and struggling before finally breaking through in
his mid-30s. As he told the Lansing State Journal:
"I remember vividly what it's like to put 38 cents
in the gas tank and drive to my second
cousin's house, so they would feed me."
Before hitting it big in television, however,
Lorre spent some time dabbling in another
creative profession – songwriting. And if
you're wondering whether any of his songs
became well-known, we've got four words
for you: "Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles."
Yes, if you've ever gotten the "Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles" theme song stuck in your head,
you can thank Lorre, who co-wrote the catchy
song that helped define the franchise. As
for his comedy-writing dream, that
didn't really happen until he got
a job writing for the groundbreaking sitcom
"Roseanne," a major break that opened doors,
launching him on a career
trajectory like no other.
After Roseanne, Lorre went on to become one of
the most successful sitcom creators in history,
responsible for the hits "Grace Under
Fire," "Cybill," and "Dharma and Greg."
But Lorre really hit the jackpot with "Two
and a Half Men" and "The Big Bang Theory,"
the pair of megahits which gave him the
Hollywood cred to make "Mom" happen. And
even though Lorre is a rarity – a sitcom
svengali with multiple mega-hits under
his belt – any aspiring writer can find
inspiration in his rags-to-riches tale.
Before "Mom," Anna Faris was best known for
her roles in comedies like "Just Friends,"
"The House Bunny," and the "Scary Movie"
franchise. With her distinctive comedic
chops and bubbly blonde persona, she was
the first actor CBS approached for "Mom."
Faris told PopSugar that her husband at the time,
actor Chris Pratt, actually read
the script for "Mom" before she did,
and by the time he got to the second page he was
convinced the role was perfect for her, saying:
"Honey, whatever you're doing,
stop now and read this."
Even though television has come a long way
since the days where everything edgy was on HBO,
Faris and Janney agreed that "Mom"
dealt with risky issues for a network
sitcom during a joint interview
with Larry King. When King asked
Faris if she was ever surprised by the
content of the show, she revealed that
she was constantly shocked by how far the
writers were willing to push it, saying:
"On a weekly basis when we get the new scripts I
always say, 'Are we sure CBS is okay with this?'"
Before "Mom," Allison Janney was best known for
her role as White House press secretary Claudia
Jean Cregg, also known as CJ, on "The West Wing."
Fans may be surprised to learn that
she didn't have her breakthrough role
on the "West Wing," until she was 40,
which is pretty unusual by Hollywood
standards. Janney did have a steady stream
of supporting movie and TV roles before then,
but nothing as big as "The West
Wing," which eventually led to "Mom."
On "Mom," Allison Janney's character,
Bonnie, had long, flowing auburn hair. Her coif
actually became synonymous with the character,
which was a bit ironic considering that
it's not even Janney's real hair. Yup,
the actor was wearing a wig the whole time
— and her co-workers didn't even know!
Janney's real hair is actually a
beautiful shade of natural silver,
and when she showed up on set without the wig
one day, the producers apparently freaked.
During an appearance on "The Tonight Show
Starring Jimmy Fallon," Janney told the tale.
“'What are we gonna do, you should've asked
us before changing your hair!' I'm like,
guys, I've been wearing a wig since
season one, but nobody knew it!"
As a recovering addict himself, "Mom"
was a very personal show for Chuck Lorre,
who got sober himself at the
age of 47. As he told TV Guide:
"Sobriety is a big part of my life, and
it's been that way for almost 13 years…I'm
eternally grateful I've been
able to find this in my life."
"I am trying so hard. I quit
drinking, I'm going to meetings…"
As far as how his personal recovery journey
relates to "Mom," Lorre told IndieWire:
"Broken people trying to repair their lives,
I can relate to that. I think we're all
in the process of doing a little mending."
"Excuse me, no one's going to be
snorting any fat rails while I'm here."
And, as Janney told IndieWire
in another interview:
"It feels like a very grown-up show for
[Chuck Lorre]. I had no idea that we
were going to be going to the places
that we've gotten to go with 'Mom.'"
In showbusiness, like any other business, success
breeds success. And in Chuck Lorre’s case,
having so many hits on his resume gave him
the freedom to take on riskier stuff — in
other words, shows like "Two and a Half
Men" gave him the freedom to make "Mom."
Lorre told IndieWire that to challenge
himself creatively, he needed to tackle
something different, something that would
force him to step into new areas of comedy.
"I am at a point in my career where I can take
some chances...If you're going to experiment,
do something that is meaningful to you. If you
fail, you did something meaningful to you."
And with "Mom," he did just that.
"Someone's spoiling themselves."
"It's for my mom. She's a drug
addict who just got out of jail."
"aw!"
Back in the 1970s, legendary TV producer Norman
Lear was a household name. He had many creations
to his name, but none as groundbreaking
as "All in the Family," which dealt with
topical issues and proved that TV sitcoms
could be intelligent and thought provoking.
Chuck Lorre often credits Lear for inspiring
him to create similarly edgy sitcoms – proving
to the world that television doesn’t have
to be predictable, and it doesn’t need to
be insulting to the intelligence of the
audience. In an interview with Variety,
Lorre said that with "Mom," he wanted
to tell stories that could take place
in what he calls a "Norman Lear world," in
other words – realism, rather than fantasy.
"You know the definition of insanity…"
"Yes I know the definition
of insanity I live with you!"
Lear, now 100 years old and
someone Lorre considers a friend,
brought a reality to the sitcom
format that had never been seen
before. And much like Lorre has done with
"Mom," Lear made history tackling tough
subjects on TV as well. In an interview
with the Los Angeles Times, Lear noted:
"People will tell you you can't do
just about anything — mention abortion,
have a gay character, write funny
about cancer. You do it anyway."
"Christy Plunkett. Jill's sponsor.
But I'm not 'sponsible for this."
It was a big surprise to the viewers of "Mom" that
the character of Jodi, played by Emily Osment,
had a fatal overdose and died on the show. At that
point, Jodi had reached six months of sobriety.
Lorre has said it was decided that Jodi would
have an overdose when she was first introduced
to the show. He explained the reasoning
behind this in an interview with TV Insider:
"Recovery from addiction is fragile. The
one day at a time trope is sadly true;
it's a vulnerable state of being that
requires vigilance. You can't ignore it."
The entire cast of "Mom" was heartbroken when
they read the script and realized that Jodi was
going to die on the show. Not only did they love
the character, but they loved Osment as well.
It was a challenge for the writers of "Mom"
to figure out how to bring tragedy to the
show and then go back to being a comedy, but
ultimately, Jodi's death showed that life goes on.
Laughter is contagious, and the shared experience
of laughing can make a comedy even funnier. This
is why it was so hard to shoot "Mom" when the
COVD-19 pandemic took away its live audience.
"Something I said changed the
course of your life for the better."
"Feels like it."
"Are you listening to this?!?"
Veteran TV director James Widdoes, who helmed
episodes of "Mom," agreed with that assessment.
Speaking to Variety, he called shooting the
sitcom during the pandemic a "logistical
challenge" like no other. Gemma Baker, the
co-creator of "Mom," told Deadline that
not having a live audience was one of the
hardest parts of finally ending the series.
"An audience was so much a part of what we
did and this whole season we missed them.
It really was a huge loss to not have that
energy and feedback and laughter. It would
have been great if we [could've] ended
the season in front of a live audience."
When Anna Faris announced she was leaving
"Mom" after seven seasons, it was a big shock,
to say the least. And while it's hard for a
show to survive when a lead character leaves,
it isn't unheard of. Similar to Chuck Lorre's
other hit sitcom, "Two and a Half Men," "Mom"
was able to hang in there for a little
while longer, putting out one more season.
However, co-creator Gemma Baker wishes they
could've done more with Christy, telling Deadline:
"There were so many things that we
wanted to address that we didn't get
a chance to…if we had a little more
time we would have gotten a chance…"
One storyline fans missed out on was
seeing how Christy would've done at
Georgetown University Law School.
Baker described how she imagined it:
Christy would've faced some challenges
– but ultimately would've overcome them.
Baker went on to tell Deadline how
she envisioned closure for Christy:
"I like to think that [Christy] got into a happy
and healthy relationship and that she
is still a part of her mother's life."
Fans can have
a lot of power when it comes to saving a
show. Case in point? The original "Star
Trek" series. About to be canceled after
the second season, NBC's deluge of letters
from fans begging the network to keep it on
saved it. The cop drama "Cagney and Lacey"
has a similar story – after it was canceled,
a letter writing campaign kept it on the air.
And when "Mom" was officially canceled
in February 2021, fans mobilized with a
50,000 signature petition. And those fans who were
in recovery were particularly passionate. To them,
it was important for the show to remain
on the air, because of the fact that so
many addicts were struggling during
the pandemic. As the petition stated:
"'Mom' has been a crucial voice in de-stigmatizing
addiction. This show has no doubt saved countless
lives by promoting substance abuse recovery
and encouraging people to seek help."
While the show did end up going off the air,
the spirit of "Mom," and how it gave a
voice to people in recovery, will carry on.
A lot of sitcoms have endings
where everything ends up just fine,
and everyone lives happily ever
after. But for a show like "Mom,"
having everything wrapped up with a neat
little bow at the end just wouldn't work.
"My name is Bonnie, and I'm a grateful alcoholic."
Co-creator Gemma Baker also didn't
want a convenient ending for the show,
telling the Hollywood Reporter:
"Because of the nature of the show, it
didn't feel truthful to have an ending
where everything is tied up, because
the show has always really been about
reality and characters showing
up for life on life's terms."
"I think it's true what we say here,
'don't leave before the miracle.'"
"Yuchh."
Baker recalled how the finale was hard to put
together because they wanted to bring the show
to a close in a way that was meaningful
and that did the best for the characters
and the audience as well, a challenging
feat even under the best of circumstances,
made more difficult by the
sudden departure of the lead.
"We'll be there, every step of the way."
"Damn straight."
But it could also be seen as fitting, how, in the
end, the characters and the creative staff
had to make the best of a tough situation,
and deal with life – on life's terms.
"FORGIVEN."